und wir sind jetzt hier in leipzig
hinter mir die leipziger europa und
eigentlich bin ich jetzt auf der suche
nach atemschutzmasken denn die sollen
wir eigentlich bestenfalls alle tragen
wir waren jetzt in drei apotheken in der
innenstadt und in zwei theorien und in
allen apotheken gab es tatsächlich auch
eine maske zu kaufen
ungefähr die einfachen masken haben zwei
euro fünfzig im schnitt gekostet die
teureren ungefähr neun bis zehn euro und
in den drogerien war es eben so dass es
dort keine masken gaben ich habe hier in
hamburg tatsächlich einen mundschutz
gefunden und zwar den hier im maritimen
look
man darf nur nicht gleich im ersten
geschäft aufgeben die
änderungsschneiderei hier hinter mir ist
der vierte laden in den ich gegangen bin
der inhaber nicht sie seit zwei wochen
selbst und die sind aus 100 prozent
baumwolle in den apotheken in denen
nicht davor war und in der drogerie da
gab es leider keine mehr die apotheker
warten schon seit tagen auf neue
lieferungen nur einen die bin ich grad
hinterher noch kurz gegangen die hatte
glück da kam gestern eine neue lieferung
von 100 masken sogar zertifizierte mit
filter heute gab es davon aber nur noch
wenige die kosten da knapp 10 euro und
auch die hier die hier gekauft habe
kostet zehn euro und reicht für den
alltag vollkommen aus wer in münchen
noch schutzmasken kaufen möchte hat
dafür die besten chancen in den
apotheken in den drogerien waren die
schutzmasken ausverkauft das ergab
zumindest unsere kleine stichprobe hier
im tal in münchen
wir waren in zwei drogerien und vier
apotheken getreide vier apotheken gab es
noch schutzmasken in einer sogar die ff
weimar die auf einen selbst schützen und
nicht nur die mitmenschen allerdings zum
preis von 15 euro das stück
die normalen op masken gab es im
zehnerpack zwischen 18 und 25 euro
das ist natürlich ein extremer
preisanstieg im vergleich zu zeiten vor
kommune